um at what point in time did you realize
like voltra Island was like
an Anthem for for just a lot of people
like it's it's a it's an Anthem in the
club it's anthem when it comes to NFL
players I just realized that like last
week at boosted Bash
May attack me like man you got an Anthem
like she's gonna be around for a minute
like
I ain't even understand it though I said
crazy because that [__] still in the
club I ain't drop I ain't dropping a
year right like no way I'm still down
there in my head like no way I'm still
relevant like
but that [__] still popping highest
popping been popping like what was
bougie bash like booster is crazy that's
just that's home though so you know of
course yeah
you know I always shut up I would say
he's one of the few guys
that if you love him when you meet him
you will not be disappointed no count
though because that's him that's him bro
for sure I do with him bro okay I'll be
him because you meet some guys and
they're like oh you ain't who I grew up
look you me boozy and you're like oh no
this is you he's a he's such a good dude
too and he's so funny like you gotta try
to
during the pandemic him in trouble rest
in peace to trouble they were doing
these pool parties I'm sure you saw the
footage did you ever see any of the
footage of the trouble boozy pool
parties with all the damn cucumbers
all these [__] sucking on cucumbers
yeah I'm trying to go to this year bro I
don't know man you got to stay out of
there man what I just feel like you know
you'll get you go you don't want to [__]
around with the wrong [__] over there I
mean you don't wanna [__] with no [__]
sucking on cucumbers bro thanks though
you got your whole life ahead of you man
don't throw it away for a cucumber bra
you know what I mean
that's my type of Porter though I like
that type of [__] you a strip club guy
um I wanna be
that's something to Aspire to be I want
to be it's like
I just can't go to the club like you
know what I'm saying something in my
head not letting me go to the club
you're smart you're smart yeah stay out
the club man I was worth it before I was
rapping I ain't never been to the club
like really I wasn't old enough so how
old are you now 2400 May 24 like so like
you never like really started to hit the
club until you were getting booked yeah
that's the time to go when there's a bag
to pick up that's what I'm telling you
like stay out bro that's what I'm saying
I remember I try to go to a club one
time in my city
it was so hectic for us to get in right
that was already I was already letting
my sit around the time I'm like man I
plan on be like
I said you know what I told people I'm
like man let's go right see next time we
come in here they're gonna give us all
their money
it's crazy because when I went to New
Orleans we uh one of my friends is a
photographer his name is John John and
uh he he like we kind of went to so
where the levees broke for Katrina
there's like that neighborhood right on
the other side that got hit really bad
yeah so we just went over there and we
got invited uh this lady invited us into
our house cooked us dinner explained to
us like how everything happened with
Katrina like how uh do you remember back
because you were obviously a kid when
all that happened I remember everything
though I remember that did happen what
was that like man going through that I
ain't lying for us it was it was crazy
because we ain't had no like working a
reliable car at the moment right so we
driving to um Houston like we was
driving in the Monte Carlo I remember
the windows was tinted but the doors
didn't um I mean the windows didn't go
down and that ain't working that [__]
no AC and it's running hot it's it's
definitely humid as [__] because you're
in New Orleans it's hot as [__] it's the
middle of this hot and sticky yeah it's
it's no AC the windows don't roll down
in a car running hot we was rolling we
was riding with the doors open on the
interstate just to get some air just to
get some in that bridge running hot
every 15 minutes so you guys ended up
going to Houston how long were you guys
in Houston uh how long was in Houston
for
I mean three months because I know a lot
of people that was kind of like the main
place that they would reloc relocate to
11 came to Phoenix too I know some you
know
things keep falling off velcro boys we
gotta velcro these things on you know me
I fixed this [__] me
um no but it's kind of crazy like like
did that did
um Katrina like hit your neighborhood
pretty bad yeah and they hit the whole
New Orleans yeah
right so it ain't really [__] up too
bad because it's bricks you know high up
yeah yeah it's high up like my house
ain't really get [__] up yeah
that's crazy who else in New Orleans
right now should we be paying attention
to what other rappers can we can we shed
some light on that you think
um
um black Migo
um Nino Calvin treaty
um luji
roll ruggy
um big pack
[Music]
coming up
this this but I'm about to I might still
try to sign or this and [__] like how
this rapping they take gee he hard as
[__] you're gonna start trying to sign
some artists yeah I'm gonna sign a
couple of them